all right good morning everyone
good morning for those of you who speak
a little bit german
it was a pretty good party last night
wasn't it so yeah i'm glad there's
at least a bunch of people out this
morning so um
i'm here today to talk to you guys
because i believe that
every mobile app should be tested
through automation i should probably
take the time real quick
um so um what i'm going to show you is
why i believe we should be doing this
and the great thing about it is that
the technologies that i'm going to use
which is adminium
apache cordova also known as phonegap
and
top code they're all backed by
javascript or web technology so it's
you know for this conference pretty
relevant so
i have a little code to excuse my um
like small breaks
in between um so the reason why like one
of the reasons why i believe uh
every mobile app should be tested
through automation is the fact that um
there's a paradigm shift going on right
now
especially like consumers like people
that are not professionals that use
uh can be like that not use they are not
using a computer on a daily basis to do
their work
they're increasingly using more mobile
devices
to you know use the internet and like
whatever is out there so
there's a shift from like the old school
desktop
browser based app to mobile apps
and um you know like mobile devices like
smartphones are getting increasingly
more popular cheaper because technology
you know evolves and you know it's only
it's only progressing it's only getting
more
um that is great because it also
opens up a lot you know new
opportunities uh business-wise and just
you know
building awesome stuff so one of the
examples are obviously instagram
very popular i mean they would found it
a couple of years ago and blew up
in like no time another good example is
like lyft or
any of those transportation companies
that
use the fact that a mobile device is so
much more in the context of a real life
because it's more like a person carries
it
um with him or her wherever they go it's
not like
you're going to a computer in your room
like you you always bring in the phone
so
you have the advantage of having the
device embedded in the context of
a person's life meaning it knows the
location
and it has all kinds of other like
information available that
you just don't get out of a browser or
like out of a desktop browser
and uh a really good example also is
like variables like the
nike fuel band you know like it actually
uses
um information that it collects
throughout the day
and then syncs it up with your mobile
phone and like presents to you what
you've been up to like activity device
and all that kind of stuff
that's just i wouldn't necessarily say
it's impossible on a computer
but uh the entry barrier is way lower
for mobile devices and mobile apps
to do that so
it's great that we get new opportunities
and all that but like opportunities also
come with challenges so
um that's kind of exciting uh but it
also can be very frustrating
and you know one of the challenges
obviously that there's not just one
mobile phone and there's not just one
operating system out there and
in particular for uh for the mobile
world you know the contenders are like
ios
android um blackberry uh windows phone
and maybe symbia not so much anymore but
you get it there's like there's like a
multitude of platforms
um another problem is that these
platforms run on like all kinds of
devices so
it's not a standard device everyone has
the same one everyone has an iphone
they're like
plenty of devices this is like a chart
that i took from a blog post
and it's the data of july 2012
and it shows you how popular certain
devices are
and um i can't really show this right
now because it's not interactive but
the way they did that is like they show
how it progressed all the time and
it moves around really fast so you know
all the sudden your phone comes out and
like it's tossed into the mix and
the problem is it you know has very
different screen sizes
um this is a chart that basically kind
of shows you
how many different screen sizes there
are like obviously like more in
a symbolic way not like you know at
scale um
the other interesting thing or like the
other thing that's very challenging is
that like
most of these devices have different
memory different cpus
you know different technologies so it's
not that easy to like provide a unified
experience
to all users using
you know just a single technology
another really big problem that brings
me back to this test automation
statement that i made is
um the way you distribute apps um
is very different from like deploying a
website and using a browser
and like hitting it it's like these days
they are like you know app stores you
submit an app to app store and that's
the way people find your app discover it
and download and use it
uh the problem with that is i mean it's
great it's not really a problem
it's great because it is a unified way
for non-technical people to get hold of
you know great uh apps that provide
great opportunity
great experiences and great services um
the problem that comes with that is
particularly for a certain platform you
have to submit your app
and if you're lucky um it actually makes
it into the app store
in like a two weeks time or so but it
can sometimes be like
you know a month or five because there's
a review process attached to it like
they want to make sure that you don't
steal data from their users and that
you're using the platform in a
in a let's say like a regulated way
like in a sandboxed way and um
the way that it works is like you make a
change you want to get it out there you
have to submit it to the app store and
go through all this process
so essentially um it's not as
easy as like running a website where you
can deploy at will
because it's your service you're running
it people hit it from their desktop
browsers
it's more like you make a change and
then you have one shot
and then like you have to wait two weeks
or cancel it and like you definitely
have to wait the time until it actually
hits the app store and people update it
and then it's also up to the people to
actually up update or upgrade to the
latest version
um so one thing that really uh you know
is key here is
quality assurance right so when you have
one shot you want to be you know you
want to be sure that when you actually
you know go ahead and you're submitting
the app to the app store
that um you know essentially this app is
is
bug free or at least the functionality
that you want to provide to the users
you have a confidence that it's working
and there's a really common way of
doing this which is called dog fooding
so companies
go ahead and like serve a development
version to the employees
like i think facebook does that because
they have a lot of employees and
everyone kind of has to use facebook in
a way even though i'm a bigger fan of
twitter
um but the thing is um
they're kind of like um dependent on
like people using it hitting bugs and
then filing reports
to actually get some sort of uh qa
process in there but it's kind of up to
coincidence it's not really systematical
and it's definitely not automated at
least the the testing part of it um
another thing is like you can't really
execute
some sort of test case repetitively
because you're like literally just kind
of
probing the app like people just use it
it's not there's no system to it there's
no there's no test plan to it
and even if if there were one it's
really you know hard to
repeat that on a frequent basis and you
know quickly
um obviously you want to find bucks
before you have your users do that's
kind of like the bottom line of all that
so um you know like that all that said
and all these
variety of platforms and screen sizes
and all that um there's like this
this initiative uh in this you know app
development world which
goes in the area that like instead of
like using some native programming
language like objective-c
or like android why not just using you
know web technologies to build
apps because we all you know most of us
in the room here probably uh
are either you know building websites
already or have built websites
but you know there's a there's a
standard here or there's standards
already and they will accept it and
and they work in the browser so why not
using them uh firefox
is a really good example they're kind of
embracing that to the full extent um
the other platforms are not quite there
yet mostly because of performance
reasons um
it's it's not quite competitive yet but
you know we'll see what happens in the
future
so my idea here what i'm going to demo
here is like an approach it actually
uses web technologies to build an app
that's cross-platform
so um i'm using um
apache cordova which is also known as
phonegap and
i found this really good app online it's
from kristoff i really don't know how to
pronounce his last name so i'm not going
to attempt it
but he built this app and i just
basically took it extended a little bit
and
i'm just going to show you guys what i'm
talking about real quick
so this is obviously an iphone simulator
it's really simple it's an
employee directory you can just search
you can scroll through the list you know
you click on
things you just get more information you
can like you know hit the call button it
will call the person or at least it will
simulate a call
um and yeah it's overall looks pretty
great
because topcode does a really good job
it's kind of like the twitter bootstrap
of
um of uh mobile apps like if you like
like myself and you don't have a really
good hand for design you may as well
just use
you know something that is already you
know pretty good looking
um but overall it's a pretty simple app
um the emphasis of my talk is
obviously the testing aspect so i'm not
like a full-on cadover
developer all right so
yeah i just talked about that yeah
codover
is basically the attempt to use native
apps that wrap a webview a full screen
web view
and make make it possible to deploy
cross
platform apps by using web technologies
and it also makes native apis available
through javascript so you can actually
on you know your web on the javascript
level you can hook into
stuff that actually happens natively on
the phone and it tries to do that in a
unified way
so the idea is to have like you know an
abstraction layer on top you know across
all these platforms um
top coat as i said is like this twitter
bootstrap for mobile apps it's really
great if you ever design if you ever
happen to build a cordova app and you uh
you know when i get something off the
ground real quick i highly recommend
that
um it's also like built with the uh with
performance in the back of their heads
so
uh in order to compete with like native
apps you know performance is key and
um there's a lot of things you can do
wrong if you if you like went to a bunch
of talks yesterday
you probably noticed that there are a
lot of things you can do wrong using you
know interactivity and like
styles and all that to like just like
bring down the performance of your app
and it's
obviously more important on mobile
phones than it may be on desktop just
because of the computation power
um that brings me to aptmio admin is
the test automation framework that i'm
going to use in my demo that i'm going
to show you in a second
atmium is a is an effort to
basically create a unified
test automation api which is based on
the webdriver json product
web webdriver wire protocol which is
very well accepted by
uh implementations for selenium
webdriver for the browsers
so there are like language native
bindings out there in all kinds of
languages you don't have to you're not
locked into a certain technology to do
test automation it's very open
and aptmium is basically the server that
uh uses native
um like native developer tools of
ios of android or firefox os to do the
back-end automation part so you have a
unified api you don't have to worry
about the you know
the back-end part of it um i heavily
contributed to this earlier this year
my co-worker jonathan is basically
working on this full-time it's entirely
open source
all of this is obviously open source um
it's it's
it's a great thing um i'll show you in a
second so
um a couple of things about atmium those
are kind of like the
the highlight points or like the driving
factors behind it
there are a bunch of like competitive
like competitors in the open source
space that do kind of the same but they
don't have these
um like guidelines that we build it on
top of or like these cornerstones which
is
that you shouldn't ins you should not
have to instrument your app in order to
test it
the idea behind it is like you should be
able to test the app in the way that
you're submitting it to the app store
like no sdks no embedded web servers or
anything like that
that's like one of the really big
driving factors because once you modify
your app you don't know if that's going
to cause
you know issues when you deliver it
because most likely you're going to take
that instrument now
instrumentation out before you deliver
it to the app store
um as i said you want to write your test
in any language
as far as i know like even for exotic
languages they're like
webdriver selenium webdriver compatible
bindings out there so you can code your
your tests in
everything from coffeescript to perl uh
you name it
um it builds on top of like well
accepted automation standards that
are by nature uh grown out of the web
uh you know the web browser area but we
basically try to
um since the ideas are kind of the same
uh like
you know evolve them to use mobile and a
bunch of my co-workers are involved in
you know standardization process with
the with the guys from web driver and
for
um to get that into the w3c spec
so it becomes legit web you know
technology standard
and on top of that there's actually a
lot of traction that that project got
ever since and you know i highly
recommend to like take a look if you
guys working on mobile apps
and and um i'm gonna use an emulator and
a simulator
uh they kind of call differently in ios
and android uh to actually test but you
can
you can literally attach a real device
to your computer and run it on your
device instead of
running it in a simulator and uh i
brought in nexus
one tablet if any one of you guys want
to see how that works i can show you
later i just don't have the time today
all right so codover is this um
this framework that wraps a web view
which basically like a
you know a full screen browser and a
native app right and that's the way it
deploys
or like it gets the functionality out to
all the different platforms
and the great thing about that is that
um if we talk into a website
this whole automation you know um
process is
basically unified because always web
technology is always the same across the
platforms supposedly it's the same
i mean it relies on the idea that like
everybody implements the standard right
which they which they do most of the
time but it's not it's not as different
as like you know you have android and
you have ios and you have very different
frameworks so like very different apis
so that's great um
also meme supports um
talking to the native part of the app or
talking to the webview part so the
different contexts
the context and you can switch back and
forth between them so you can
automate the web part of the app which
is the web view which is forked over the
actual app
but there are things that you you know
you can test through the web app if
you're hooking
like if you have events hooked up to
some native api that javascript exposes
through cordova
so sometimes you have to switch from the
webview context to
the native context in order to like
automate something and then switch back
so uh the great thing is that you're
actually using the same exact protocol
but the semantics change because in one
way you're talking to
the native part and the other way you're
talking to the webview part which is you
know web technologies
um the way that it looks like is um
i try to make it a little bit clearer by
providing a code example so the top one
here is talking to native code
as you can see it uses like a kind of
familiar
dom type of like lookup get elements by
tag name but in fact
attack name here doesn't doesn't mean a
tag name it doesn't it doesn't mean like
i'm looking for a span or a diff or
something it looks
it in fact uses a ui component class
which is a table cell
and it will return all of them so you
can do something within the automation
script
the idea here is to use the exact same
api
and it's already you know specified so
we're not going to change it
but uh you can use the same semantics
and just you know for now forget that
you're not really
looking for a tag name it's just a ui
company component class
but it works it works just fine um down
below is
the um the counterpart it's like when
you switch to the webview context
you look for a spam you get a list of
spans you can work against it in between
you have to do a bunch of other commands
to
let you know know you know want to talk
to native for the webview part
okay um without all further ado let's
just run the tests
so what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to run the tests on ios first
bring up the simulator i dropped some
delays in there so it will execute a
little bit slower so we can actually see
how it um
you know does its magic
and like on the side here is mocha as a
test runner
and it will just do the bdd style
interface and you know show you
what what tests are executing at the
moment it gets a little bit more
exciting towards the end
so um
like the setup phase is usually a little
bit slow
so this one is really interesting i'm
like switching to the native view at the
end and i'm scrolling up i do a flick up
which you can't do through the web uh
automation
or like the web context part of it as
you can see here
um so i mean this is uh this is pretty
cool stuff but
uh it gets even better because i'm using
the same exact code and run the same
tests on android without changing
anything
so you basically can automate
cross-platform but you use the same
exact test cases like you don't have to
implement
like very different code to like do the
tests
um here there was like a dialog box like
a modal dialog that i clicked it's also
a native
um you know api that gets called and i'm
going to show you the code on how that
works and how you can switch in
into the native context from the webview
context
but before we do that i'm going to kick
off the android test so you can see
that it does the same thing for android
so this is the android simulator
emulator
and uh hopefully it'll bring up the app
you can see it's running
and let's move it a little
on bit right side in moca you can see
how it executes the tests
so yeah it does the exam exact thing
it's a little bit redundant to like
watch it all
happening because it takes a while um
let's go back to the presentation
um so my test implementation i'm going
to like we're going to dive into a
little bit of code here
it's based on it's all you know it's all
node it's uh javascript
the the bleeding edge part here is that
i'm using
node 0.11 that comes with like uh es6
and harmony um
and i'm using a part of it or like a
part of the specification which is
generators
um test code is fundamentally sync
because you know user interaction is
you know a user can only do so much and
it's usually like one thing at a time
so using callbacks as much as i don't
have a problem with callbacks
like the code just grows to the right
unless you break it up and functions
but then it's not as coherent so my
co-worker jonathan he built a library
called
um monocle which is a port from a python
equivalent
that basically uses generators to make
this api a little bit nicer and like
what it does is like yield callbacks
here
as you can see here and it will unwrap
them and return
the value for you so up here that's a
bad example it yields a selector and it
returns the value
and when you hit a yield uh node won't
move on it will
like like pause execution right there
and then uh
later on when the value comes back and
returns the value and keeps going
so this is a very short example but as
you can see it's all like
nicely lined up and it's from a from a
test authoring point of view it's just
nice to read in my in my opinion
all right let's look at the code
so so i spent a lot of time on actually
like creating a nice api on top of mocha
and like uh that basically takes care of
like getting your app
like set up on the on the simulator
which mostly adminium does but i kind of
want to abstract that away from the user
like from the from the developer in that
in that sense so i created like a nice
api where you can basically just drop in
like the package name and the action
name which is you know some like stuff
that you need
to uh specify when you create a code
over app it's always basically the same
thing
but and then you can basically just
start coding tests you don't have to
worry about android or ios you set that
through an environment variable that the
test runner picks up on
so it's a bdd style interface that i
coded against and as you can see here
there's a described block
and and i'm like basically calling this
before each method that um we'll just
activate the webview and then i just
write my test code
without going into much detail here the
thing that i wanted to highlight is like
this here's the actual test like the the
yet statement it's a yield it i just
shortened it and um it's basically just
the sequence of steps it's really easy
to read
i'm using css selectors mostly to get
hold of elements and click on them and
like we tried values and then i use like
as an assertion framework to just make
sure that you know what i'm expecting is
actually happening
um what's really interesting here is
that that part down here
i built this uh method uh like this
function
it's actually a generator but it's
wrapped in a in a in a function
that is called native sequence and that
lets you whatever you put in there will
x will be executed in the native
context and not in the webview context
so
the interesting thing is i'm dismissing
a modal dialog here
and as you can see up here this is the
the function definition or actually the
generator
this is obviously different because ios
and uh
and android are different in the ways
you have to interact with like native
code
so there's a little bit of like platform
specific stuff that you have to do
but whenever you talk to webview it's
the exact same code
all right um so
what's next so since i said like every
you know mobile app should be tested in
an automated way um
it should also be part of a build right
so um i thought like the scope of this
talk is already
you know pretty um comprehensive so i
didn't want to get
ci in there and all that kind of stuff
but like um
it's essential if you know if you want
to do that on a
in an automated fashion to make this
part of a build running on a you know
jenkins server or travis or stryder
any of those open source solutions or
proprietary solutions for that matter
um the great thing is that like my
employer sauce labs we're running uh at
mem in the cloud
and if you happen to work on an open
source project we do that for free so
you can just use that
um otherwise it's a really good way of
like scaling because
executing functional tests are way
slower than unit tests
and executing a scale on a single
machine can take a while so
that's a great um great way of like
getting around this problem and
especially if you're doing open source
you don't have to worry about you know
costs or anything like that
a good starting point for all this is um
our smoke tests right like you
you just want to see is your most
important flow through the app working
like let's say you you're booking
something and then you have a credit
card checkout process or the credit card
is already
in the system you just want to make sure
that the user gets from end to end so
smoke tests are a good starting point
but you know the more the merrier
obviously
it's really important to not confuse
unit tests with functional tests so
the great thing is like since we're
working on the web you can you can
heavily test your
small parts of the code using javascript
unit tests the only problem that you
have with that is that you
obviously when you code them in in
chrome or in firefox they're not running
on the actual device right
so it's a good way of having like
integration tests like wrapped up in
functional tests
um it fulfills a bunch of pro like a lot
of purposes
for that matter and yeah it's it's it's
great stuff and you know what it's all
open source so the tools are out there
they work
and i did this proof of concept
implementation here that i'm gonna
open source and everyone can look at it
and use it and make it better
and um and that's why i'm saying every
app should be
tested in an automated way because it's
you know it's available the tools are
there
there's no excuse um
and that's uh basically all i've got and
i have a bunch of links here at meme i
always like the the automation framework
uh please check that out um we can
always use contributions any kind of way
sample codes um
fixing bugs all that kind of stuff um
gadmium is like you know
phonegap and admin this is like what i
showed you this is basically the
the sample app that i used and it has
code in there that like does this whole
nice abstraction using generators and
all that which hopefully will
end in nodes 0.12 so you don't have to
use the harmony
command line option to activate them
and it also it will have all this code i
haven't pushed it out yet but it will
it just want to follow the community
process of getting it in there
yeah and other than that there's cordova
and top code cordova is really great
so it was the first time i got my hands
basically dirty with cordova but it's
it's a really great framework and it
also uh gives you a
multitude of like uh apis so you can
like interact with the actual app
so you can you can set geo locations you
can get the battery life status and all
that
um so check that out feel free to like
uh hit me up on twitter if you have
questions or like
come you know find me talk to me i can
show you how to execute that stuff on
the real device
or show you the guts of the test code or
like what's behind it and all that
and other than that that's all i have so
yeah five minutes of
q a i guess
i love that the guy that looks like me
he talked about phone gap that's awesome
it also gets you cheaper haircuts yes
hi i'm max from mozilla um working on
firefox os localization infrastructure
stuff like that um one thing that we've
been looking at
is actually doing screenshots as part of
the automated testing so that you can
actually have
a visual test afterwards without waiting
for the whole execution part
right have you thought about stuff like
that i think this is actually in the
making i'm not sure
what platform i supported so far um i
know that like on our platform on sauce
labs
it works because it's built into the
service um but i think fundamentally we
want
the the framework that we're using to
support it and not you know make that
dependent on the platform
i do know that my co-worker jonathan
worked with malini das from mozilla
who's like working on marionette to
actually get firefox os support in there
as far as i know that actually works
i don't know the extent of it but uh if
you want to know more about this
feel free to check out the project and
you know if you can't find the
screenshot feel free to create a github
issue and then we can get it in the
whole community process
and all that there's also uh i can shoot
you a link but there's plugins for that
for cordova
for ios and android actually i have a
question for you does firefox os
implement a screenshot in api
it does cool that's the benefit that you
get when your
host is actually the author of the
framework you're talking about
do we have any uh more questions
come on guys i have a question actually
are you guys gonna start doing work with
uh medic
uh which is the continuous integration
stuff that film i wrote
for cordova um i mean phil works for us
now so there's a good chance
but i'm trying to dig out the info on
this one i mean
i would just i would say it's not
impossible um yeah i'm just not deeply
involved i'm just kind of like i was
curious about cordova and
and how that works with automation i
wanted to do a proof of concept now i'm
talking about it but um
potentially cool
i mean it's it's it's pretty slick yeah
um i mean like i can't take the credit
for it i really have to like give my
co-worker um jonathan here joseph lips
all the credit for it um
the good thing is like we he ported the
implementation of uh
python twisted that we use internally in
salsa for infrastructure so you had a
really nice api already that you know
have
been using for a couple of years um i
think it's great too
there's a little bit of controversy
behind like how to handle errors
which is really not a big deal in test
code because when an error happens you
just want it to bubble up and like have
the test runner like
make it visible to you um there may be a
little bit more work required to
actually use it in a different way but
it's
you know it's pretty great it makes code
super nice but yeah i appreciate that
thanks cool
so um give give my doppelganger a round
of applause and we'll
we'll have um we'll have a couple
minutes to set up
the next
you